pro-democracy groups from Myanmar are
holding a protest in
[Music]
[Applause]
Thailand the demonstrators outside the
UN office in the capital Bangkok calling
for a return to a civilian
Administration in neighboring Myanmar as
the country marks three years since the
military took power leaders there
extended a state of emergency on
Wednesday while the military is facing
tough resistance from RE fighters who
intensified attacks on Army bases and
posts in
October Tony Chang reports from the time
Myanmar
border Dawn on a hillside in eastern
Myanmar in late January the forest
crackles with the sound of gunfire 3
years on myanmar's Military has less
control than the day it launched the
coup right now that it is already
military doesn't control you know most
of the country at least 75% of the
country especially the Border areas but
their presence is still felt in K State
ethnic Ki forces have surrounded
government troops in their bases but
unchallenged air power and artillery has
stopped them from being overrun Rebel
Fighters and civilians are suffering a
high number of
casualties in Shan state where the
offensive began in late October
alliances and coordination between the
ethnic armies myanmar's Army has lost
control of vital trade routes and border
crossings with China and the more the
rebels fight the more they
learn our better few experiences have
made us into different soldiers we are
learning from fighting and fighting
while learning we know more about their
forces and also we have better
communication between our own
soldiers while many of the official
border posts remain closed or controlled
weapons supplies and Personnel move
freely through unche Che jungle
Crossings there are still parts of
myanmar's border which are heavily
fenced off like this but in the last 12
months in Thailand China India and
Bangladesh strategic border positions
have fallen to ethnic armies you can now
come and go as they please but General
Minong li who led the coup has shown no
indication he might change direction
despite signs of concern within the
ruling Elite kunai Jen has been dealing
with myanmar's milit leadership for
decades on behalf of one of the largest
ethnic armies he's the kind of Captain
that when a six when a ship
sings He will sing and then take all the
passengers with
him that's what they say I'm I I hope
it's not
true on the western coast the military
is under attack in the strategically
important port of sway rakine state has
been under martial law since the
violence against the ringa Muslim
minority in
2016 but even those harsh controls have
failed to hold back the resistance Tony
Chang Al to zero on the thayar
border Phil Robertson is the deputy
director for Asia with Human Rights
Watch she joins us now from Bangkok in
Thailand good to have you with us so
three years since the military call how
meaningful is it that the authorities
have loosened registration election
regist ation rules but at the same time
they're extending the state of
emergency well it's not that meaningful
in terms of that election because no one
is going to participate in an election
that is held under the offices of Mong
Ling in the military coup government uh
it's simply not acceptable it won't be
free and fair and I expect uh everyone
including angang sui's national league
for Democracy party which won the last
election uh would not take
part the extension of the state of
emergency is of course something that
they're going to continue to do because
they don't have any other answers uh for
what to to to take on
next on that point it's going to say the
military's control does seem to have
slipped in recent months doesn't it what
do that meant for the human rights
situation well it shows that the
military uh is is losing control it's
never really had popular support for its
coup uh so this is really best
understood is the military against the
people of Myanmar uh it's not
necessarily a civil war it's a war
against a military that's highly
unpopular uh and the important thing to
also understand uh is that I think that
this military uh is increasingly going
to use rights abusing uh attacks on
civilians as part of their modus operand
going forward this is what we're seeing
with the use of artillery uh the aerial
attacks by their uh fighter planes and
their helicopters attacking against uh
local people against uh civilians crimes
against humanity are being committed by
this military as it on its back backf
foot uh increasingly cornered by these
ethnic
armies and is that producing any splits
within the military leadership how uni
unified are
they yeah that's a that's the difficult
thing and that's what everybody's asking
about uh and and it we have not seen uh
this military split in the past there's
only been one cou cou attempt in the in
the history of the Myanmar military back
in the 1970s so the reality is they're
sticking together um we just don't know
how long they're going to be able to
hold it together uh increasing we're
seeing on they on under pressure on all
sides uh in the North in the East and in
the west and uh the people within
Myanmar themselves uh in the cities uh
are still demonstrating peacefully
demanding uh restoration of their rights
and restoration of democracy
and all of this of course causing a
humanitarian situation two million
people displaced from their homes what
are they now facing
yes well they're facing a very difficult
future uh it's estimated by the UN that
as many as a third of the people of
Myanmar the total number over 18 million
people need urgent humanitarian
assistance uh they're talking about uh
you know children dying of uh active uh
severe Mal malnourishment uh you you've
seen the poverty rate shoot up to over
half of the people in the country uh
this has been a economic social and
human rights disaster uh for Myanmar
since the military took power three
years ago and it needs to end and the
International Community has to step up
and do something about it the UN
Security Council needs to impose an arms
embargo and we want to see action
against aviation fuel sanctions against
the fuel that is being used by the
myanmar's military to bomb its own
people
right all right thank you so much for
your thoughts on that appreciate
it thank you